Hello, everyone.
My name is Brian Dorsey,
and we're going to
talk about load balancing.
So as you're probably aware,
load balancing is a critical
part of nearly every scalable
service you might want to run
on the internet.
And luckily, Google Cloud
Platform Compute Engine has a
very scalable, powerful load
balancer built right in.
Basically what you do
is you configure a
pool of your instances.
And the Load Balancer will
automatically direct traffic
among them, spreading out TCP
connections and [? UDP ?]
packets amongst all
of your instances.
As long as they stay healthy,
they get traffic.
And if they become unhealthy,
the Load Balancer will no
longer send them traffic until
they become healthy again.
And you get to define
what exactly
healthy is for your instances.
What happens is Compute Engine
will send HTTP requests to
your instances.
And when they get a
200 response back,
it's considered healthy.
And if anything else comes
back, it's unhealthy.
So it's completely under
your control.
Let's go ahead and take
a look at the demo.
So what we've got here is an
App Engine application.
When I hit this Start VMs
button, it's made a request to
the Compute Engine API, and
we're spinning up some
instances to run this
demo workload.
It's a fractal generator.
And as the instances come up,
they're running a startup
script that downloads a go
language fractal generator,
and spins that up and
starts it running.
As the instances have gone green
here on the demo, that
means the instance is up and
it's starting to go through
its boot process.
And as soon as we start seeing
check marks, then those are
actually running this
fractal software.
And this is basically intended
as a proxy for your
application.
You can imagine any sort of
CPU-heavy application--
this is taking the place
of that in the demo.
So let me go ahead and show
the fractals here.
On the left-hand side, we've
got a single instance
serving this up.
And on the right-hand
side, right
now we have 10 instances.
So we can go ahead
and add more VMs.
And as we zoom around, even
though we have new VMs coming
up, we see both of them
working well.
And the one on the right, things
are coming in faster
because we're actually
cooperating, using multiple
instances to pull this up.
And that's all transparent
as far as this client
application's concerned.
Each side is just hitting one
IP address, and the answers
are coming back.
If something were to go wrong,
say we head behind the scenes
and we cause a failure in this
case, but something happened
to one of your instances, we're
going to go ahead and
get rid of number two.
And it's zero-based here, so
we should see this one drop
out, and there it goes.
And we can still zoom around and
nothing is changed as far
as our client application's
concerned.
It's still sending and receiving
requests, still
moving fast.
We've added new instances in and
we've dropped one out, and
all of that's transparent to
both our application and all
of our clients.
So let's come back.
Thanks for that.
And I also want to stress that
this is not just a virtual
machine serving this
traffic up.
This is Google's network
infrastructure acting as your
load balancer.
So our network infrastructure is
actually routing your data
to your instances.
And what that means is, if you
have a big spike in traffic,
you don't have to wait for
virtual machines to warm up in
order to handle that traffic.
Google's network infrastructure
will
handle it for you.
So please give it a try.
We'll have some links to the
docs and other details down
below the video.
So take care, and happy
load balancing.